okay so things got a little bit heavy
last time so let's have a nice fun goofy
silly episode with absolutely no
political implications whatsoever right
[Music]
Rapids in the UK or as it should have
been called spiders in Sheffield
so episode 4 series 11 of Doctor Who
probably the one I'm least impressed
with overall and it just feel it feels
very filler in a lot of ways it feels
filler in the same way that something
like the Lazarus experiment feels filler
it just yeah it feels like they hit on a
notion like what's something the doctor
could deal with a big spider yeah how
about a bunch of big spiders how about
like some big spiders and then like one
originally big spider yeah sure cool go
somebody go right that I mean that's
what it feels like it feels like
something that was come up with in a you
know in a room full of just people
spitballing ideas then it got assigned
to somebody who was an idea that nobody
had passion about it was just something
that they did cuz hey you know what we
got to fill out an episode with
something and it's not bad for being bad
actually as far as that kind of episode
goes or at least episodes that have that
vibe to them it's probably one of the
better ones but generally when I get
that vibe off an episode it's a bad sign
so oh boy where do we start with this
well you know what before I get before I
[ __ ] because I'm probably going to
mostly with this again it's not awful
performances are all pretty solid I'm
actually really Graham is really growing
on me quite a bit at this point they do
a really good job I think especially of
justifying his decision to travel with
the doctor with the other two they're a
bit more just like what we just kind of
want to go but honestly that flies a bit
more when the characters as young as
they are I mean they're at that age
where you know kind of on a whim you go
hey randomly I've got the opportunity to
travel Europe yeah sure I'll do that
yeah not say all young people are like
that but like it's more believable
as an element of being young and being
youthful and being at that point your
life where somebody of Graham's age it
you would expect him to be settling down
you'd expect him to have been having had
those experiences and the easy way to
have him be like wanting being the
TARDIS was like well he always lived at
home he never left the town he grew up
but that would have been the lazy way to
do it instead I like the whole idea of
him going look I'm grieving and I know
the only thing that's gonna help his
time and I kind of like the passage of
that time to be filled with stuff like
this
I like that quite a bit um so I dug that
I'm not in love with Yaz's family but
again they're not actually bad it just
rings too many bells of the domestic
stuff that I haven't liked in the past
like roses mother and Martha's family
and Clara's family that time just and I
just I I don't care for that stuff I
just don't so I don't really care about
them turning up but again if I set aside
my own distaste for that sort of thing
it was fine
Ryan's solid he's good I like the energy
that he brings I feel like he didn't
have quite as much to do in this one as
the other two but yeah he brings a good
energy to the group I like that
I Johnny Whitaker honestly I feel like
she is clicking for me a little bit more
every single episode I don't know if
that's just because I'm getting more
climate into her way of doing it or if
she's actually easing into the part a
bit better no idea cuz I don't know what
all of these things were shot in so who
the heck knows but I really get the
sense I love the just sort of the the
nature which he approaches things and I
love she feels very committed to the
non-violence and I love that she's like
there's this giant spider and she's just
kinda like okay so you're not supposed
to be here stay there I'm gonna figure
this out like talking to a spider stay
there I'm gonna figure this out I like
that I like that you know there's there
are ton of weapons that's an obvious
solution she's like nope not even new
not even an option so I like
that it's funny also one of the things
that did come out of her interactions
would be as this family that I actually
liked but it wasn't the family that I
liked is what they brought out of her
that I liked which was that she seems to
have retained Capaldi's tendency to
basically just be rude be a be rude
through blunt honesty
but I think there's a key difference
which is that she does it with a smile
whereas Capaldi did it while being
grumpy so you know she can say oh no go
ahead and make your horrible I forget
what the dish was yeah you know me do
you want me to go take care of this
while you make your horrible food it's
like she's just trying to be helpful and
she's just saying what her understanding
of the situation is it happens to be
rude but that's kind of she doesn't care
and not and not like in a Capaldi I
don't care about people's feelings away
but like it probably doesn't even
register to her that that was kind of
rude buddy but not in a way that comes
across like they're trying to ape like
like an artistic sensibility or anything
like that like because she's just so
peppy and pleasant about it I kind of
like that I like that balance of that of
that accidental rudeness while removing
the grumpiness that that compiled these
sort of version of that hat I think it's
kind of cool I like that there's one
thing Whitaker's doing that I really
don't like and this is nitpicky as hell
but I like the way she wields the sonic
screwdriver and like I said this is
super nitpicky but there's something
about the big exaggerated every time she
does it twice in this she can't just
point it has to be what once fine but
when you do that like every time you
busted out to open a door like that's
that's like I want somebody to call her
out on that if she's got to keep doing
that I want one of the commune Scala do
you have to do it with that big flourish
every time because otherwise that's
really gonna start to bug me if I'm just
supposed to buy into that cuz it's it's
it's too much so other than that I mean
it's big spiders what do you want the
they're pretty well shot that pretty
well handled and pretty well built up as
far as this sort of thing goes they're
fully functional I'm sure if I was
arachnophobia which I'm not I'm sure
this actually would have a decent shot
at properly scaring me because the they
do build the tension towards the shots
and the reveals of spiders that buries
points quite well again though it's you
know it's not something I'm inherently
afraid of and the the title says it all
is like so there's no surprise and this
generally stuff that actually scares me
or and settles me is where I can't quite
wrap my head on what's going on or
there's under there's something that is
and existentially scary about it the
empty child hits me on that level but
like it's just a big spider I can wrap
my head around that as I say I wouldn't
be terrified of a giant spider in real
life but like in entertainment like no
no I understand that too well to be
scared by it but you know it they shot
it and they handled it well enough the
explanation was really cheesy like we're
really just going with a basically a
toxic-waste mutation is it 1985 again
like that again maybe it's just because
this Doctor Who I'm not above that kind
of schlocky explanation for something
like a giant spider it's just it seems
to played out it seems too cliche
honestly I was expecting something more
ridiculous like somehow something that
had been going on
you know warped the sense of time and
the spiders had reverted to a more
prehistoric state of state of being or
they had slipped through from an
alternate dimensions where spiders were
the dominant species of the planet and
they grew in a quartz with it you know
it's something something a bit more
a bit less played out than mutated by
toxic waste which yeah I don't know but
then I'm really annoyed even having to
talk about this the character of
Robertson I don't like him I don't like
him because of how on the nose it is and
I am actually really irritated and even
having to talk about this I'm especially
irritated and having to talk about this
coming off of Rosa which you know I that
that episode put me through a bit I had
to do two videos on it and I'm I was
looking forward to basically a pilot
cleanser and they stick this in so okay
so we have an American businessman who
owns a chain of hotels who very much
enjoys firing people who skirts
responsibility is all about assigning
people to do a task and just keeping as
far away from the actual day-to-day
execution of it as possible he is hiring
a presidential run makes in an effort to
point out he's not a politician but he's
a businessman who knows how to get stuff
done but it's okay because it's made
canonically clear that oh no he's not a
trunk analog he's planning to run
against Trump he hates straw
he's still a trump analog okay it this
is you had him say fire and fury this is
it's it's painful and I think part of
the pain of it is is that it is so
specific I don't have a problem with
Doctor Who being political I definitely
don't have a problem with doctor who
being allegorical but yeah so like I
really like episodes like oxygen which
is a very blatant attack on the ex
theoretical extreme of capitalism which
is I mean I think it's perfectly valid
because it's not necessarily about
capitalism is bad honestly you can do
that story with any form of any you know
way to
you take it to an extreme it becomes
horrific that's kind of what happens but
I like things like that I like I didn't
the execution had a lot of problems but
I like the concept behind something like
the Saigon invasion inversion where you
know we have our eye we can draw the
connections to immigrant stories
radicalized Muslims and and things of
that nature like there's a very there's
very clear connection but it's not
necessarily a one-to-one it's highly
applicable but is also allowed to serve
and function as its own thing there's no
reason for this guy to exist at all much
less the way he does except to parity
Trump and that is unnecessary and stupid
and annoying and distracting more than
anything else everything like when he
first showed up my initial thought was
oh hey it's Chris Noth cool and then the
instant somebody mentioned you know this
could hurt you in 2020 I was like oh god
no and then they kept dropping more and
more and more and more stuff and I'm
just gonna just stop stop is it every
time they did it it took me out of it
and this is not an issue with any
particular political stance this thing
is or isn't taking I honestly don't
believe that it is taking a political
stance it's just poking fun at the most
obvious traits of someone while at the
same time trying to go all right oh
we're not making fun of him cuz we're
establishing this is somebody just it's
ham-fisted
it's unnecessary it in no way feeds into
anything else going on in the episode
it's completely superfluous is
completely removable I don't know why
it's there as much as I might take issue
with some of the execution of things
like the Saigon invasion inversion I can
look at that and go there's a reason for
those allegorical things those
connections those implications to be
there because they impact the story
nothing about this guy is actually
relevant or impactful to the story you
did like logistically the closest they
come to justifying him is through the
integration of his businesses that
causes this problem like okay but you
didn't need you you didn't need that
complicated explanation for toxic waste
under a building and it didn't have to
be a hotel either it could it it could
have been any building story would be
completely unaffected so my annoyance
with this is partially its presence and
again I don't have an inherent problem
with the presence of political stuff in
Doctor Who I've outright flatly defended
it before but like here the reason it
annoys me is because it has nothing to
do with anything it's not feeding into
anything it's not thematic of anything
it's just they're being clunky and
annoying and awkward and I hate it and I
I don't I really I would JIT amelie hate
having to complain about something like
this and I I really dread combing
through the comments on on reviewing
this episode because of that character
and I can't make a case of well he's
here because blood if there if somebody
else thought better of this character
and his depiction of everything else
please explain to me why he needs to be
there why it helps the story because I
can't think of it I can't think of what
he does that adds to it in any degree
greater than the level of distraction
and irritation that he brings so I'm
really sorry to have ranted that long
about this one specific element that I
wish I didn't even have to friggin talk
about but it just it it's one of those
things that took an episode that was
otherwise fine it even had some good
elements I don't think this I don't
think I ever was ever gonna love this
story I don't think I ever was gonna
think this was some great piece of work
just because
it's it's very very much a
monster-of-the-week episode of Doctor
Who I tend to not love monster the week
episodes of Doctor Who but it just sinks
it down to a much lower level that it
there was no way this could have been
breezy and silly and fun and instead
it's grating and annoying and irritating
because of him because of this one
character so arachnids in the UK what
did you think about it whatever your
thoughts were drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it please keep
it polite whatever your political stripe
is whatever you think about what the
show is doing whatever you feel just no
personal attacks against me against
other commenters against the makers of
the show just keep that to yourself okay
I've had to clear out a lot more
comments than this standard when dealing
with Doctor Who episodes lately so just
pull it together guys come on if you can
do that drop something down in the
comments and let's talk about it so
there's a whole bunch of stuff down
there as well because there's buttons
and there's links including a link to
the patreon if you feel like supporting
me that way but you know what if you
don't don't sweat it because folks at
the end the day you are the council I
just run the meetings and until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]